winter is coming and the road has not
smoothed out yet
game of thrones season 5 episode 6
unbowed on bent unbroken as seems to
have been the trend so far this season
there's some good there's some bad and
it's a mix of the two sides i suppose
i'll start with what's good here we see
the return of elena tyrell
oh i was missing her it's great to have
her back it's great to have her energy
her bluntness i just love having her
back that
the instant she showed a big smile on my
face also on the positive side of things
lord baelish i know some people really
hate him i think just because of how
skeevy he is and he is skeevy but he's a
skeevy in a way that i really enjoy
watching him and just
his ambition
continues to amaze me the scope of it
and also his apparent ability to really
push himself towards what he's after
it's
it's astounding and i still enjoy
watching it here's a surprise on the
positive sides of things
sansa
she has a moment in this episode and it
is just a moment
but it's been so long in coming where
she takes control she takes control of
the situation and she's not just a pawn
and she puts her own stamp on that
moment and just
thank you
finally and i wish i could say that i
had some more good things to say about
this episode but i
kind of don't and actually i can sum a
lot of it up pretty simply which is that
i've come to realize one of the things
that's been bothering me that i haven't
been able to put my finger on one of the
things that goes on in this episode as
well is that the sort of wheel spinning
thing that i've talked about before but
there was something else that i couldn't
quite put my finger on what was going on
and why it wasn't sitting well with me
and i figured it out there are too many
personal agendas now to clarify that
there have always been personal agendas
going on in this show and pretty much
every character has their own agenda
going on but what always made the show
fascinating up to this point is those
personal agendas were being pursued
within the confines of a larger agenda
you know the battle for the iron throne
the struggles at the wall daenerys is
conquest of the slaver cities and you
know within that greater conflict you
would have people with their little
personal agendas that we that they were
pursuing but right now we don't have the
bigger picture it's just all these
little things going on the only thing
that's keeping its eye on the big
picture is what's going on up at the
wall but everything else it's just these
little niggling agendas and the big
picture the big scheme of things it just
it isn't there and it probably wouldn't
bother me so much except season four
was an epic example of how the little
agendas and the little moments affected
the big picture but it doesn't feel like
these little agendas are affecting
anything greater than just whatever it
is the individual's pursuing them are
after and pretty much all of the issues
that i would have in this episode fall
under that umbrella i suppose there's
two other things that i didn't like that
i feel the need to single out one is
that there's a fight scene that just
drove me crazy because it's between two
characters in very similar outfits to
each other fighting against three other
characters and those three are in very
similar outfits to each other and the
between that fact and the way that it's
cut it was almost impossible to follow
what was going on going on in that scene
and from what i could make out it was a
cool fight scene with cool choreography
but i just i every time it would cut i'm
like wait who am i watching now and it
was just sloppy and then there's just
what happens at the very end of the
episode and i'm not gonna miss words on
this i hate it i really really hate it
and i can't explain why because to
explain why it's getting spoiled so i
have a feeling this is gonna be
something i'm gonna be really delving
into when we get to the end of the
season and i do my season overview when
i get into spoilers but right now just
not happy you know what since i'm on a
bit of a negative kick i'm just gonna
roll with it what's your least favorite
episode of game of thrones we can talk
the entire series or we can just keep it
to this season however you want to do it
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned
you